let's talk about miss Ellen DeGeneres ah
the poor multi-millionaire TV celebrity
who was stuck in her mansion while the
help cleans her windows so she's getting
ripped apart by woke Twitter and it's
it's kind of woke Twitter how the locust
of Twitter it's just the blue cheeky
journalist types that are piling on yeah
just you know what they're piranhas
there was blood in the water yeah none
of them actually care about Ellen at all
they're making fun jokes they're like oh
I can make some funny joke and they're
like well do you really care about Ellen
no no but I can make funny jokes out of
it though it's like that's what we're
seeing it's like a mob you know yeah
it's it's just it's just a mob of people
running for the street screaming and one
person does something and everyone else
wants to be a part of it so they jump in
no one really knows why they're angry
but hey man it's fun to be a part of the
crowd right it's true so here's here's
what we've got an excellent source for
you today our source today is
Cosmopolitan magazine the the bastion of
great journalism and and here's what
they wrote since it's incredibly unsafe
to go outside if you're not an essential
worker these days many celebrities have
been social distancing in their gigantic
homes while slowly unraveling we saw it
happen with gal gadot and our celebrity
friends who decided to sing who decided
to sing imagine instead of donating some
of their millions we saw it happen when
Vanessa Hudgens went an Instagram live
and said deaths related to kovat were
inevitable and we're seeing it again
with Ellen DeGeneres as part of her new
temporary Ellen Show setup Ellen sent in
her living room in front of a flat in
front of a floor-to-ceiling window
overlooking lush greenery after giving
some words of encouragement to her fans
Ellen then compared her new normal to
being in jail she first joked today I am
filming this in my living room because
it has been because it has the best
light and sound and all the other rooms
in my house are filled with toilet paper
then she added this is like being in
jail mostly because I've been wearing
the same clothes for ten days and
everyone here is gay there is so much
wrong with that joke from a woke
perspective that's true first of all
wearing the same clothes is like the
least of the issue of being in jail
right but also saying everyone is gay
wow that's that's bold to make a rape
joke about our prison system it's true
no wonder she's getting torn up a bit
yeah it's a little it's due
than I expected it to be I actually
didn't hear that whole the whole thing
yeah the the the people there aren't gay
by choice in many circumstances yeah so
we're luck or they're not yay at all and
right things just happen yeah dude but
not not have no saying not funny but you
know what I'm not somebody who gets bent
out of shape because someone said a joke
I don't find it funny yeah I'm like oh I
get what she was going for yeah I don't
care yeah I'm an adult I've got bills to
pay I'm not gonna cry about this well
apparently there are people who will cry
about it and we all expected as much
obviously this is a tone deaf comment to
make anytime but it's especially grating
now as inmates have an increased risk of
catching Crona virus and feel like
sitting ducks one man at a facility in
Louisiana even told NPR they have not
done anything to isolate anybody here at
all people are still coughing every
night man they're a bunch of sickly
people in this camp I just pray
something happens soon surely that's not
what's happening in whichever mansion
Ellen decided a social distance and film
her daily talk show in just a hunch
predictably after people watched this
segment they dragged Ellen for the
comparison making this one of the many
times in recent memory that people were
not laughing along with her
they say remember the Dakota Johnson
interview and when she hung out with
George W Bush one variety writer oh here
comes woke Twitter Carolyn Frankie
tweeted what a great look for Ellen as
thousands of people sit in actual jail
cells just hoping for the best without
soap and basic protection others said
Ellen really is the worst and people are
dying I'm afraid to leave my house every
day but I have to but okay go off Ellen
social isolation is bad stressful and
causes increased depression and anxiety
but it ain't jail I mean there are so
many tweets about this some of the
tweets are actually funny this one I
love this one like it Reducto has said
it's sort of like being in prison says
woman eating yogurt in bed who also has
voting rights so I don't care if Ellen
makes a stupid joke it is kind of
telling though when you see that other
video that video that we've that you oh
yes oh yeah no but you want to get you
want to go straight to the darkness I
mean it just touched on that though rice
was talking about exactly that and
something that we're straight for the
data straight straight into it it's
fitting look at this I'm not gonna I'm
actually gonna play this video because
brutal it but it is pretty brutal it's
true I mean they have masks but there
but they're not there tonight right next
to each other
cram their rooms so there's a this video
that's gone viral and we got to be
careful because we've seen viral videos
in the past just because violent mean
it's true yeah but it's also but it's
purportedly of dude in jail and one
dudes wheezing because he's got Co vid
and this this the dude filming's like
what are we supposed to do this dude's
literally dying right now I don't know
I'm supposed to be doing yeah
and he's like he's just sitting right
here like what okay I can't go anywhere
yeah he's like we can't even social
distance meanwhile you got Ellen chillin
in her mansion like oh man I'm in jail
hehehe so here's a funny thing the
people are dying quote riot you know
what man I hear you people are dying
yeah but they've said that about
literally everything it's it's like true
you walk outside and like some kid drops
a glass of milk and they're like people
are dying and you're like it's spilled
milk dude did you use a silly analogy
but they literally cry about everything
yes in food like the biscuit I didn't
finish eating the biscuit you know
there's starving people nobody but
people are dying as a quote is used in
every single social justice protest so
like right if you say something like I
believe in free speech like oh people
are dying you're like I have no idea
what that has to do with like louis c.k
making an offensive joke sorry I just
don't understand but that's what that's
how they say so now it's funny because
one of the things we talked about is how
the social justice activists kind of
have no leg to stand on yeah because a
lot of their Vande politics
nobody cares now that over people are
dying yeah exhibit now they're like
people are dying and it's like well this
time you're right alright other times
you got me now yeah this time that's why
it's funny I think it's funny that we're
reading like woke Twitter and Cosmo
making fun of Ellen and we're all like
enjoying it mm-hmm
there's like something interested like
something amazing is happening Alyssa
Milano came out and she she sides with
Joe Biden yeah and then both sides of
the culture were come together in
harmony holding hands to make fun of
Alyssa Milano yeah and you get Bernie
Sanders dropping out today and then you
get the Trump supporters in the Bernie
Sanders supporters like holding hands
like in harmony like ragging on the
Democratic
it's weird I said it like a month and a
half ago when this whole thing started
happened like is this gonna be our space
race like that's gonna bring everyone
together it really does feel that way
like we're all coming together like
realizing celebrities aren't really that
special you know what's really special
is the people that are being I mean
they're not going out and working by
choice they have no choice they have to
go work it's like we're all calling them
heroes and but they have no choice it's
like they're risking their lives to be
out in men that countless different
things that they're doing you know I can
only think of the Lord of the Rings meme
what's wrong
Gimli he looks at like a listen he's
like I never thought I'd die fighting
beside an elf oh yeah and I'm like I
never thought I'd laugh at jokes by woke
Twitter making fun of you know a
celebrity mm-hmm side by side so they
just show a bunch of tweets but I got to
be honest it's just people trying to get
on the bandwagon there's anybody really
care that Ellen made a stupid joke no it
has nothing to do with Ellen right it's
like oh I can make a funny joke and
people will spread it around and I'll
get some hits and take it some like come
on over the plate yeah mm-hmm what and
somebody just like quoted it someone
some of it's just not even like I'm
angry about this what is this
yeah Ellen might want to address this on
her next YouTube ad well she deleted the
video apparently oh did she
yeah I guess you took it down that's
what don't know it's right here isn't it
is it is it up okay it's up I'm not
gonna play that thank you
apparently somebody's you're saying it I
mean celebrities have been for the most
part going insane yeah like what is this
can we not are you gonna weekend you're
giving me the business okay I guess they
kicked me out because I what is this oh
I see what happened they were like why
don't you don't you pay for this so we
covered I don't want to be covered it
yeah but we made fun of celebrities
quite a bit and a couple weeks ago it's
fun and everyone seems to be in on it
it's kind of a cool thing you know like
hey let's make fun of these people it's
cool because we used to just needlessly
prop them up everybody want to know who
they were what they were wearing where
they where they took poops and like you
know I mean like every people people
would like hide in bushes take pics of
them
now everyone's just making fun of them
so as much as like the the ellen
degeneres thing is a bunch of people who
just don't don't really care about Ellen
but they might be a part of the crowd I
kind of dig it you know what I feel like
there's one celeb that that might be
above this Ryan Reynolds
Bill Murray Bill Murray Bill Murray can
just do whatever he wants like a handful
I don't know I feel like Bill Murray is
he's kind of like the craziest one yeah
of them all that can just pop into a
your party and be like hey what up if
Bill Murray's not gonna he's not gonna
lose it though I feel like he lost it
long ago
Bill Murray made a video uh-huh and he
was like hey everybody you know Bill
Murray here I hope you're all staying
safe just want to make sure you're doing
all right and you're staying home have a
good one
then people would be like whoa what
happened to this guy oh my god wait but
Bill Murray's normal yeah say something
crazy he's like you know kind of like a
Ryan Reynolds kind of character yeah
what is kind of like Bill Murray yeah
yeah so I'm not gonna read through this
article but it's just funny because uh
New York this is the cut from the from
New York mag the celebs are losing it I
saw this and I said to myself I read
this article two weeks ago
yeah they keep losing it yeah they're
consistently it just came out like five
days six days a week go mm-hmm and then
we have this one's funny from The
Spectator why we love to hate
celebrities one world together at home
is a weirdly complacent name yeah and
this is just again I thought that I
cared or like read the opinion pieces
about celebrities yeah but I noticed
there was something unifying all of us
we used to be unified by who knowing the
celebrities and talking about them
mm-hmm now we're unified in our hatred
of them there are love / hatred well you
know it's interesting I heard that you
know Bollywood yeah in India so like it
froze I don't know is like saying
India's Hollywood I heard that in India
there look down upon hmm whereas I'm
like in the United States celebrities
are like looked up to okay yeah so I
don't I don't know that's true okay I've
just you know people have said to me
that you like in India they don't
consider it to be like a high-class kind
of thing we're in America they're
celebrities they're like the rich and
the wealthy and the famous never wants
to be like them and I'll stuff now we're
now we're just
of them all hmm that's kind of a cool
thing because if we can discourage
people from trying to be like these
awful people yeah then you know and be
more like doctors yeah or Isis or
grocery store food stalkers well no I
was talking about like I mean sure yeah
that's that's necessity right now but
you know that back in the day it was it
was more like you know you to aspire to
be like a doctor or the president or an
astronaut or a scientist that discovers
my life on another planet you know what
kids want to be today
celebrities kind of your clothes it's
more specific influencers even closer to
BRR oh really
yep I mean it might occur so this was I
think last year that is survey like what
do you want to be when you're an adult
like the biggest groups at youtuber like
YouTube famous
and then there was I mean I would
imagine today it's like tick tock okay
yeah but you want you guys want to hear
a funny story cuz you weren't you
weren't around for this sure when I
first moved to this house okay like it's
kind of empty and there's a knock on the
door and I walk up to the door and I
open it and there's a bunch of like
fourteen-year-old girls standing on my
porch with their arms crossed like you
know looking all no sassy
fourteen-year-old girl life and then one
girls like she looks mean to us are you
a famous youtuber and I was like what
because my mom says you're a famous
youtuber and I laughed and I was like I
don't know and she goes I bet you're
rich and I laughed I was like what she
goes yeah and then the other girl was
like my dad said you're really rich and
I'm like whoo I just moved here who are
you people
yeah what who's going around and saying
all these things is not true and I was
like your parents my make way more than
I do and then they were like I can't I
can oppose they asked me what I was like
is that is that all you wanted to know
can I can I go back to like playing
video games or not this playing Warcraft
or something and but I think the reason
I don't know why they why they came here
did it it was funny I was like these
weird little kids but yeah you're a mini
celebrity to them well nobody here to me
I grew I grew up in an era of YouTube so
YouTube to me isn't special
maybe it's interesting because I feel
like we're always looking up to the
people who came before us and
so to the person like men when you get
to that point when you're in your 30s
and you're like you are the head of your
you know your office or something okay
like let's say you're no longer the
apprentice you've now taken over the
principal you know tasks at your at your
company maybe you've become like the
chief the the chief chef or whatever to
you it's just normal it's like I've been
here for a long time and now I'm doing
my thing yeah but other people come in
they look at you and you like you're the
man you're the boss right so for me it's
like I'm just like I'm not I'm just a
guy who started phone myself like I
don't know anything about YouTube but
these younger people see youtubers and
they're like rock stars yeah you saw you
you were there when there was no YouTube
yeah you know so now you know and you've
seen it and you've grown with it but for
me it's it it's still like it reminds me
of that episode of The Simpsons where
Homer wanted to be an inventor okay and
then he made that he's like he was
obsessed with Thomas Edison so he made
this little chart showing Edison and all
the things he'd invented by a certain
timeframe and then him okay and then
when he finally went to Edison's like
office museum or whatever he saw the
exact same thing where it said da Vinci
and Edison and so he was like wow it's
just like me and Psyche kind of a stupid
thing cuz Edison was just like a
businessman right but but that's kind of
the idea it's like these kids look at me
on YouTube and they think like oh wow
and for me I'm kind of like I'm looking
at TV anchors and like multi-millionaire
this is the person you look up for look
up - um - yeah yeah I wouldn't say I
look up to anybody no I'd say like in
terms of production quality and wealth
and success it would be like primetime
cable news anchors or personalities but
no one in particular no I mean I think I
I think one of the things that'll lead
you to success is thinking everyone's a
[ __ ] so I think I think everybody on TV
is stupid like Ellen especially you know
but I mean pretty sure I could take a
joke no I don't really think she's
stupid she's obviously smart enough to
be successful on everything she's done
yeah yeah you know that means she's
avoided pitfalls and has been able to
expand her company in terms of like the
news space I think no one does it better
than Joe Rogan whether whether he you
know will publicly say it or not he's
the highest he does shows where
interviews
smart scientists and stuff and it's like
the biggest podcast in the world yeah
you know I look at the cable TV people
and I do think it's fascinating that
they have less influence these were the
that's like the old guard it's kind of
fading away and dying out so anyway
that's that's kind of the point you know
whether whether it matters or not as for
the celebrities I'm actually excited
that the old traditional TV style stuff
is burning out and they're trying to be
YouTube stars yep they're trying to dive
into YouTube and the company not working
nope like get out of my house that's
literally what Ellen was doing and it
ended up blowing up in her face I mean
everyone's talking about Ellen right now
so it's like Alyssa Milano everyone's
talking about Alyssa Milano yeah but
maybe that's all she wanted was just
people talking about her maybe but
they're more sensitive to high-profile
brands I don't think that's exactly what
Ellen was doing now she wasn't trying to
get attention no no I know that's what
I'm saying just corny yeah she's she's
quirky and honestly it is it is kind of
funny and you know if you take out any
of the well the future you know this
money being offended part it's kind of
funny it's like George Carlin would say
and it's like oh well that's what George
Carlin would say you know but like
listen it's like well her saying it's
like being in jail mm-hmm that's the
joke it's like ironic right she's a
wealthy individual and a mansion
comparing to jail like that's literally
the joke exactly now that everyone here
is gay I thought was pretty brazen
considering you know gay so maybe that
was part of the joke right why and her
wife is also gay but I mean talking
about prisons and the people there don't
go in like Cara Lee gay you know she's
look I'm not gonna read plain about a
joke that's offensive if I'm the last
person to I'm the one who turns on the
count dank EULA videos and laughs at
them and they're like as offensive as
they possibly come but you know you you
you you give the woke Twitterati an
opportunity to pretend to be angry yeah
there you go
exactly that's really yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you